okay everyone thank you so much for
coming out on this beautiful evening I
know you've got a lot of other things
you could probably be doing on it on a
night like this one and thank you too to
my fellow panelists and especially
Howard marquel David Rosner I'm sure
have an amazing story to tell right it's
a right all right okay so welcome
welcome to clue you nice yes all right
okay so let me let me also thank the man
who made all this possible Roger hertog
for providing the money to fund the
hertug global strategy initiative this
is a research program it's one in which
we bring students from all across the
country to come together for a summer of
collaborative historico research on one
of the most important problems in world
politics that is understanding the
history and future of pandemic threats
in global public health last year we
looked at nuclear terrorism next year
it'll be climate change and
international security and so the idea
is that instead of creating a permanent
program or even a department we're
trying to see if it's possible to build
custom made a research team to take on
these kinds of problems to work across
disciplines to bring together
undergraduates PhD students and bring
together some of the the leading
historians and practitioners on these
important problems so I'm going to also
thank the communications department of
the mailman School of Public Health the
center for the history and ethics public
health also at the mailman school and
and I want to thank again all of you for
coming so I want to introduce Steve
Morris is going to be monitoring the
Powell tonight one of the many qualities
is that he's incredibly modest and some
people have good reason to be modest but
not Steve Steve comes to us is one of
the leading figures in the field and in
fact when I tried to bring together
people in the history and future of
global public health all I had to do is
mention Steve's name and I
found time and again people would come
out and do anything it seems for for
Steve so I'm not going to regale you
with as many accomplishments you could
read that in the program you could also
read more about the panelists tonight
and so Steve is not going to spend a lot
of time introducing them let me instead
just turn things over to him so you can
get us started thank you thank you very
much and thank you all for coming it's
really a pleasure after that
introduction all I have to say is I feel
in very distinguished company and I
promise you a very interesting panel to
tonight we have in order I guess Howard
Markel actually at the end who's done a
tremendous amount of work on 1918
influenza and collar on many other
things he's professor director of the
Center for the history of Medicine at
the University of Michigan and professor
of several subjects next to him David
Rosner our colleague at Columbia who's
co-director of the Center for the
history and ethics of Public Health and
a professor at the mailman school of
public health as well as in the
Department of History George korche dr.
Cortes principal deputy assistant
secretary for preparedness and response
that's quite a mouthful but we call it a
spur the assistant secretary for
preparedness and response at the US
Department of Health and Human Services
and does this job after a distinguished
career as commander at you Sam read the
US Army Medical Research Institute of
infectious diseases and other places
next dr. Randall Packard who's professor
of the history of medicine at the Johns
Hopkins University and william welch
professor of the history of medicine in
the institute of the history of medicine
so there are very few such places and
probably most of them are represented
here next kavita sivaramakrishnan who
recently came to us from harvard is
assistant professor in the Department of
socio medical sciences at the Melbourne
School of Public Health and we were
delighted to welcome her here tonight
and not least although he will speak
last ehresmann Ella who will talk about
the the uses and possibly the misuse and
limitations of history so at each of
these speakers will do and we we were
very lucky also to have Helen Epstein in
the audience as a discussant soybu deter
so what I'll ask each of the panelists
please to summarize in about five
minutes very very briefly your thoughts
about what history can teach us about
the next pandemic the role of historians
and informing our understanding of
pandemics and how we we view them David
David Rosner we're gonna have to be
first or Howard no you first please oh
no okay okay uh we've been going for
those of you who are not in on the joke
we have been speaking non-stop for the
last six hours and so it is a you know
for those of you who haven't been here I
apologize but this is the Howard and I
you know lost lost it puts stuff in the
other hand will let me just start out by
you know thanking Steve and and Matt for
organizing all of this is an
extraordinary you know extraordinary set
of events that's better going on
throughout the summer so this is uh
hopefully we can add a little bit to the
discussion of what Kent history teach us
about both the pandemics of the future
as well as the pandemics of the past I
this morning started out a discussion by
quoting a eminent eminent figure in in
economics former president of Harvard
who began began we began the morning by
discussing a memo he wrote in which he
talked about in this memo where we have
to how we can start dumping our
industrial wastes in foreign countries I
started out in this way
by looking at this memo because I my
perception of the future of epidemics is
that while we're focused on what we
think we know there may be events that
are kind of looming in the future that
we are not prepared for I particularly
am really involved in thinking about the
ways in which the transformation of
international social relations economic
relations political relations are going
to affect how we think about the
responsibilities of different countries
and different countries economies to one
another and specifically what we talked
about this morning was the problem of
industrial waste for those of you who
know the history of industrial waste we
have become a rather clean country
relatively clean country over the past
40 years basically by exporting many of
our most our filthiest industries
whether it be the lead industry which
I'm focused on or the plastics industry
in the chemical industry much of the
work that we now as a modern industrial
society depend on much the products that
we depend on our really are really
products and materials the dirtiest part
of which are produced in other countries
so my little addition to this morning's
talk was to say that when you think
about pandemics and when we think about
future crises in public health what we
have to realize is that they're going to
be new kinds of problems that we have
never even conceived of as part of the
global pandemic epic or global epidemic
that are going to come to haunt us
specifically I was talking about and
thinking about you know the exportation
of lead production which is still the
basis for our Prius cars and our
computers and and many of the products
we use every day the dirtiest part of
which is being done now in Peru and
Chile and destroying lives and
destroying communities in those areas
whether we think about a big pharma in
Africa and exporting our research to
countries that have no ability to
define how they treat their client
they're their patients that would be
another area but that when we think
about pandemics we have to think beyond
both national borders or you also have
to think beyond infectious disease I'm
going to stop there because that's all I
wanted to really a dime into the
discussion this morning is that we think
we know what we're talking about when we
talk about pandemics but I think the
definition of what is a pandemic will
change pretty dramatically as both
social political and economic
relationship shift over the coming years
so I'm going to stop there's at five
minutes worth thank you David okay thank
you very much next out dr. Howard Markel
dr. rosner already said what I was going
to say so I've delighted to be here I
this have been a wonderful conference I
want to thank Matt and and Steve for
arranging it has been great great
discussions and opinions and really a
lot of fun I was thinking of walking up
here of a wonderful line by a great
public health expert Herman Biggs who
was commissioner of health in New York
City later became Commissioner of the
state of New York was very instrumental
in introducing the techniques of
bacteriology in terms of epidemic
disease control in the 1890s well into
the 1920s issues of tuberculosis control
and so on and literally of a hundred
years ago almost exactly he was
announcing the opening of a TB
sanitarium in Otisville New York that
was sponsored by the city of New York
and he gave a very famous speech with a
very famous phrase public health is
purchasable and that most of the
diseases that humans are subject to and
he said both acute and chronic our
issues not only of the disease entity
itself a microbe or Oregon going arrived
but of social conditions of economic
conditions of political conditions and
that there is hope that we can fix these
things these underlying in
equities inequalities these problems of
housing of nutrition and access to care
and so on it sounds like we still have a
lot of work to do whether you're talking
about acute or infectious or chronic
diseases pandemic is a word that's been
changing quite a bit epidemic pandemic
you classically contagious diseases
referred specifically to a disease that
you could transmit by touch and that was
classically smallpox and erroneously
leprosy infectious was actually a
different disease that you could spread
by other means people didn't know
necessarily what they were caused by in
antiquity or even much later 1500 1600
years later but miasmas or later on
respiratory droplets or gastrointestinal
diseases but there was a real
distinction between infectious and
contagious for many many centuries that
now very few people unless you're
historian think about in fact infection
comes from a wonderful Greek root which
means to pollute to die e ye to stain
because it is thought to stain an
environment or the atmosphere an
epidemic was many people in one area
getting it and pandemic many people in
many areas getting that particular
disease now contagious or infectious
diseases tend to spread but as we're
finding so to do the chronic or other
diseases that we see heart disease and
lung disease as related to smoking gun
injuries automobile injuries respiratory
diseases because of pollution of the air
and things like that so we do have to
change our definitions on the purist in
me someone who has studied to spend a
lot of time studying infectious diseases
and classical epidemics and foreign
teams and things like that likes the
old-fashioned stuff but I also know
there's always change over time and I
think we need to think about is that
concept that very very noble concept and
hopeful concept that Public Health is
purchasable
I think about that phrase quite a bit
because it is and personal by of the
wealthiest countries in the world that
have more money that have ever been
amassed by human beings and it wouldn't
take all that much when you think of
what we spend our money on we never
hesitate to spend hundreds of billions
if not trillions of dollars on various
wars or rescue and capture missions and
so on yet when it would take maybe ten
dollars a person in America to not
eradicate but really put the damper on
tuberculosis and dengue and malaria and
diarrhea diseases around the world what
should we do that and I would like to
submit that we you know we were talking
about the Matthew particular talking
about the passing of nation states and
we're seeing this quite a bit in issues
you're using the metaphor of war but
also of who attacks who terrorism is a
perfect example of that but if you
really want to break down nation-states
talk about disease and don't just talk
about infectious disease but the the
health of others really does affect us
the pollution in other places of the
world really does affect us who are more
fortunate and so the question is can we
afford not to purchase public health and
so I'd like to close with that what are
we doing and what do we have to offer
and I I think history shows time and
time and time again that we are very
very concerned about public health when
there's the Q crisis but then there's
this profound amnesia once it passes
SARS what's that aids that was a problem
influenza yeah forget about and but the
same thing about diseases that we don't
see aren't affecting us are right in
front of us and I think we have to do a
better job historians as well as
practitioners of Public Health of
showing you know not to sound too much
like a Hallmark greeting card but no
man's an island and it's actually John
margarita guard but um it'd be a nice
greeting good but um you know we all are
all interconnected and I I we're not
doing enough we need to do more as a
global community I'll stop there thank
you very much dr. Jorge Cortes area of
responsibility in the office as
principal deputy deputy assistant
secretary for preparedness and response
includes the public health response and
preparedness for all sorts of
emergencies ranging from bio defense in
general to various natural disasters and
influenza pandemics when do I sleep yeah
so when do you sleep um actually
hopefully never it's interesting coming
out of a program of Public Health and I
start off my comments by saying Public
Health really is a contact sport it is
it is science applied to large scale to
affect large-scale changes in health and
Howard mentioned a variety of those of
you know occupational environmental
infectious behavioral development of
social norms and and so the office that
I represent preparedness and response
and I share it's interesting i'm an
interesting nexus because muscle
professor at the Bloomberg School of
Public Health on loan to the government
so um so it to a certain degree at any
point in time I think switch have to say
that's not my responsibility but um or
that I don't deal with that right now
but prepares in response is always
contextual over the three years or two
and a half years that I've had the good
opportunity to be engaged in in this
office here is what has been on the
plate it started off one month into my
tenure with h1n1 it was followed rapidly
by an earthquake in Haiti with
devastating effects in a cholera
epidemic that followed on that oh by the
way we now have an oral oil spill in the
Gulf of Mexico that's affecting the
shoreline and tens of millions of people
that then gets followed by
a major reactor damage based on you know
a large-scale event in japan earthquake
and in resulting tsunami on and on and
on it goes and and right now we got a
breathing room but just to throw it into
context a few tornadoes in places like
Mississippi and and Missouri so you know
we move from the local to the global but
there's a commonality in every one of
these particular types of events and
that is number one the decision
processes that we that we deal with
generally with the same group of people
almost require access to timely
information and access to expertise that
is not resident in our little group act
access to to you all at at schools
public health or other technical fields
and um surprisingly access to the
historical context of looking at our
place in time versus other places in
times and decisions that were made now
biological terrorism biological warfare
is as a misapplication of biology and
it's not a pandemic it's a plan demic
people plan for this to happen and they
and they have a very specific set of
decisions that they make on what they're
trying to effect and and why and we've
watched an evolution of biological
warfare from really as Howard said a
city state or a nation-state capability
to more and more the likelihood of
possibility that it is not the
large-scale event of you know
intercontinental ballistic missiles
coming crashing down from a former
adversary but a cheap way to to make a
splash and achieve an end which for
terrorists is you know their job
description is their name it's it's
create terror so we look at this and and
and ask how does one then strategically
make decisions about where to make these
investments you know what's the level of
impact in terms of economic and the meta
impacts what's the likelihood was the
intelligence tell us about what type of
it event is going to happen and then the
real dilemma will we be able to mount a
credible response to that and what is
the time frame in order to get there and
over the course of the last 10 years or
so there's been a huge investment by
this country in biological defense
stimulated by 911 Thrax letters um such
that there's probably been over 60
billion dollars of investment now you
you know Gracie I loud that that's a lot
of money and has it all gone for naught
no actually from from my vantage point
if you look at public health as an
infrastructure prior to these events it
was on the ropes there was a very few
doll there were very few dollars really
being applied to large-scale preparation
planning here in this country in public
health it was the benefactor to a
certain degree of some of these events
because we saw that without the ability
for local communities which is really
where all of our planning needs to be
aimed at to use these funds to have the
capability to communicate with each
other as needs arise without that
investment and a lot of the money has
gone into creating a public health
infrastructure which sad to say as
budgets start getting rolled back we're
going to see a retrenchment in that
capacity but as we look at what
biological defense has to do with public
health we see other spin-offs as well
more and more often we look at these
these unknowable events and bio defense
is equivalent to what we see in emerging
infectious diseases what we see in rare
and neglected diseases there's a lot
more commonality there than there are
differences why is it that for instance
malaria which affects you know hundreds
of millions of people around the world
does not have the same level of interest
and impact from the pharmaceutical
companies as does you know obesity or
diabetes what is it that we know about
bio defense relative to the the ability
to stimulate interest in pharmaceutical
companies to prepare and provide the
medical
measures that that we're working right
now to build up and so as we look at
these gaps there's a lot of lessons
learned another major lesson that we've
learned over the last three years is our
ability to have a science responsiveness
program to the events around us as
somebody says in the White House never
waste a good crisis and the crises that
we've seen have have provided us a view
of there are there are many times where
we're looking to ask where is the data
that helps us to inform on what our
responses should be and it's always
after the fact why didn't we take the
time to establish a meaningful you know
clinical trial or gather baseline data
or or develop a registry and so we're
starting to take that on in a really
meaningful way for instance there will
be something called a public health
research review board or the ferb which
will be a national IRB to be able to
respond we this is a lesson that we
learned in h1n1 when we try to be able
to roll out a new antiviral parameter
for the treatment of highly highly sick
patients in ICU so there's a lot that we
learn at a bio defense that helps us
inform a public health and there's a lot
that we're learning in an hour response
to to these events in terms of the
endemic diseases as well so I just want
to follow on by saying what have we
learned the 1976 swine flu affair that
the book that you all read or many of
you read was the first mandatory reading
as we crack the books open for 2009
pandemic h1n1 and we directly benefited
from knowing where were the where were
the points of error or possible places
where they should have seen the red
warning signs and may change and and we
use that to our advantage now it wasn't
perfect and I there was a whole lecture
i can give you on what went right what
went wrong in 2009 but we didn't fail to
look at
history with regard to what had past
administrations and past experts learned
so a science responsiveness building
partnerships this is a Howard's point as
well we have a national health security
strategy now that's been published I
urge you to look at if you're not
familiar with it NHS s the ability to
create resilience across communities the
real mandate to rely on every day
procedures and systems because that's
the system that you're going to turn to
when it comes to an emergency response
and then other things like looking at
platform technologies that have multi
uses as opposed to single uses and
finally importantly the equity of access
we're struggling right now with how many
of you here are older than 18 and
between 18 and 65 you have to raise your
hands i can probably done but how many
of you have children that are you know
in the pediatric population do you
realize that for many of the bio defense
products that we're developing we're
fine with regard to use of those
products and adults but there's no data
for the use of those products and
children and think of the inequities
what happens when we really need to use
those and you as the parent gets or gets
to receive the vaccine or the drug but
your child can't so those are some of
the things that we struggle with as we
look at you know what can we learn from
the past and apply to the future thank
you very much George it's striking you
know that the first book you cracked
open was a book of history so hopefully
there is a lot to be learned from
history and our our next panelist
professor Ronald Packard has written
histories of pandemics of malaria and is
it work on one on dengue so the writing
of the history of pandemics obviously is
an art well maybe it's an art so the
topic here is what can history teaches
about the next pandemic so one is there
will be a next pandemic
too little little we are currently doing
will prevent that from happening now
think about right we are developing
surveillance systems which are
supposedly allowing us to identify
pandemics as they begin and so that we
can hopefully stop their progression and
stop their spread but these surveillance
systems look at very proximate causes of
pandemics and do not necessarily look
upstream far enough to see far enough in
advance when those pandemics will occur
so we look at the conditions of slums
building up in citizens cities like New
Delhi as breeding spots for disease but
we don't look down stream to say well
how do those slums actually come to be
and to why do those people move into the
cities and what forced them into the
cities and how did that have to do with
the failures of agriculture and how did
those failures by agriculture have to do
with neoliberal economic policies so so
where do we look when we're looking for
those indicators more profoundly the
failure to take seriously the social
determinants of health has left us
vulnerable to pandemics if we are not
going to do something more profoundly
about transforming economies for
transforming the ways in which
populations live on the planet then we
are always going to be sitting here
waiting for the next pandemic to come
and we may be able to predict it earlier
in terms of how fast it's going to move
but we're not going to be able to
prevent it from happening so what can we
as historians do in that situation well
what I think we can do and what I try to
do is to try to illuminate what those
contexts are and to luminate what those
chains of causation are in ways that
allow us to see the larger issues that
doesn't necessarily mean anyone's going
to do anything about it we talked this
morning or this afternoon a lot about
waiting for the call from the Pentagon
or from the CDC to bring the story and
aboard to help us I don't expect to get
any phone calls my prescriptions are not
particularly
or not well particularly received
because in some ways they're seen as
beyond the scope of Public Health but I
think on the other hand there is a
danger for historians to write for
policymakers to think about how what
kind of prescriptions that we can put
forward for policymakers because the
policymakers work within paradigms and
with parameters that allow for the
doable but don't necessarily allow for
what needs to be done and if we write in
ways that actually targets those in
Korea and creates awareness of those
types of solutions we encourage them to
continue doing those kinds of solutions
without actually looking at the larger
and broader questions that are at play
here and the larger forces that are at
play so finally what I would say is that
there is another problem with looking at
the history of pandemics and I think
Howard referred to this in another way
just a minute ago in that it blinds us
to so much else that's going on in the
world on pennette pandemics have sucked
up a lot of energy popular imagination
and resources i was in atlanta in this
past week visiting my grandchild my new
grandchild and i had occasion to drive
by the cdc and i do this a sort of
regular basis i taught at Emory for 10
years and had a lot of context the CDC
it's like oz I swear it's it's another
world and when you think this was all
built on bioterrorism and concerns about
pandemics and not about concerns about
poverty malnutrition
and a whole range of chronic illnesses
that are affecting the world's
population and with the exception of
AIDS or probably having a much higher
impact on the burden overall burden of
disease and which get very little
attention so while I applaud the
organizers for you know raising the
issue of pandemics I urge you all to
think beyond pandemics and to think
about those other diseases those other
problems that are not getting attention
in which are plaguing masses of
populations around the world thank you
very much I'm delighted to welcome next
dr. kavita simo drama creation is Eva
Ramakrishnan who's recently come to our
school the mailman school of public
health so in many ways this is a welcome
to Colombia as well as a welcome
obviously to the panel Thank You Stephen
that's very generous of you so I thought
I'd build on something that randy said
just now and start with a little
anecdote really but two years ago when I
was writing a paper on a recent plague
epidemic that happened in a West Indian
town called Sula hmm in 1994 in fact
there was a plague epidemic in surah and
so I went to interview an Indian
parliamentarian he represented an East
Indians State the east indian state of
thing goal and when I asked him about
you know what are the occurrences of
epidemics one of the comments he made
was he said you know you can only have
epidemics against a background of Health
so to be able to identify an epidemic
you have to have a background of Health
it's not enough to be an epidemiologist
and say you have to have this particular
epidemic curve you have to have a
certain number of cases and you report
an epidemic so the point I'd like to
make is it's not only about the social
determinants of health it's also about
the politics of health because this this
parliamentarian was not only speaking
about poverty in Bengal which is endemic
he was also talking about the
relationship between region and center
between West Bengal as a province and
what are the politics of a province that
reports an epidemic to a national center
which is based in Delhi funded by the
World Bank and which accepts certain
kinds of reporting and again then the
tension where epidemics bring up which
is the tension really between the
nation-state and the global and too
often we really focus on ethanol
anthropologist all of us tend to look at
the global and the national but we don't
really tend to see the intersections
within countries itself and the
political determinants that really
influences and when when my work
progressed I realized that the political
determinants of epidemics are crucial
and they come up really in the issue of
what I think are the semantics of
epidemics during the nineteen
ninety-four epidemic the big question
really was is it the plague or not and
it not only poised the international
community with you know the scientific
community within India itself but there
was constantly this this tension really
of proving and summoning enough
scientific evidence to be able to prove
that it was the plague or not and
somewhere there I think people really
lost lost touch with the real question
because it was not only about proving
the science of whether it was the plague
or not but you really needed to ask why
a country like India does report an
epidemic or not why do countries report
or don't report epidemics why do state
governments not report them and it's not
only about trade and economic losses
which is you know which is what most of
the press reported at that point of time
that India was having a huge number of
trade losses it didn't want to report
the epidemic and 19 9th in the 1990s is
all of you know were the times when both
Latin America and countries like India
was starting to liberalize so you
opening up your economies and you want
it to be global and the last thing you
want it was the utter sort of
international and social embarrassment
of having a medieval epidemic arrived
when you wanted to only be seen as being
global so it's it's partly about the
trade and economic losses but it's also
about it's also about the pressures
which I think were reflected in the
Indian press at this point of time about
about the Orientalism literally of the
ways in which epidemics are being
reported and so many I mean these are
reports which were there I mean if you
looked at Time magazine
at that point of time I mean where do I
epidemics occur and how our economics
reported across contexts so you would
see the indian national press reporting
about the little province of gujarat
where the epidemic occurred as being
sort of an undeveloped and a sort of
fringe that didn't really belong to the
nation at all so there was a sort of
lack of ownership within the country of
a fringe that was medieval and didn't
belong especially when you wanted to go
ahead him and there's also India itself
poised with the sort of reporting that
was happening across the world and the
utter embarrassment of course was that
countries like Bangladesh and you know
and that's where the region becomes
really important the issue is of course
of you know what the North thinks of the
south and the world South thinks of the
north but also what your regional
neighbors determine and and public
health becomes important in terms of the
visions you have of yourself because of
what you know your strategic neighbors
think of yourself and that really
affects the public as well as I think
politicians much more than what the
right you know what the USA or the UN
thinks of you at that point of time and
of course one of the Indian newspapers
which was very right-wing said you know
finally the plague will ensure that
Bangladesh is not going to send all its
illegal immigrants across the border to
India because you don't want those
immigrants and for the first time you
had a country that was much poorer much
less powerful than India which seemed to
have closed up its borders so there's
this issue of regional tensions which we
need to remember and so I mean the
things I'd like to flag really is the
issue of semantics as in who names in
epidemic and this brings up this issue
of politics and power and finally really
that I think each of these pandemics
historically bring up we think that
there's a singular vision of Public
Health but I think what it taught me was
there are simultaneously many visions of
Public Health at the time of a single
epidemic and in some ways the politics
of these many visions you know helps us
really understand the sorts of social
tensions that exist so let me give an
example at the time of the UN report
that was produced immediately after the
plate pander may have a play depa demic
in surah the indian guy look at the
plague epidemic as being something which
was planted possibly by result
you know the bioterrorist conspiracies
that could possibly exist in Pakistan it
spoke of laboratories where the plague
you know where the plague microbes may
be manufactured so there's a whole sense
of global health or a vision of Public
Health which is not located within India
it's not located within the spaces of
poverty and dirt that exists within
India it's about science and technology
it's about germs and pathogens that are
constantly moving and on the other hand
the report that was produced on the pend
on the plague epidemic which was a local
regional report produced by the gujarat
state government talks about the plague
as being a disease of development it's a
disease and it's an older sanitarian
sort of vision of public health which is
exactly what randy was talking about
which is about poverty which is about
all the workers in Surat who were
exposed to dirt and disease that have
been floods in Surat before so there's a
different sort of memory of Public
Health there's a different sanitary
envision compared to them you know this
global health vision that we speak about
so that's the last thing really that I'd
like to say that we have to remember
that what epidemics teachers and what
pandemics teachers is that you know even
when we look at it in a linear fashion
and look it look at it historically even
at a particular historical moment there
are several competing visions that rise
out of social inequalities but also out
of the political inequalities that don't
allow you know that have these groups
constantly jostling to to project
certain kinds of certain kinds of public
health officials thank you very much
Kavita with a last but not by no means
least but as a very nice I think finial
and finishing touch to wrap up the panel
dr. erez Manila professor of history at
Harvard University with the perspective
on the limitations of history and its
uses thank you first of all I have to
clarify I'm not
there is a medical emergency what can
history teach us about the next pandemic
this is the question before us and I
have two answers for that one is
everything and the second is really not
very much at all and what do I mean by
that well everything because history is
the sum of our past experiences and
anything we could possibly know about
the next pandemic we know about because
we have history to guide us not very
much at all because although the past is
all we have it still doesn't allow us to
predict the future history doesn't work
as we said today in perfect cycles so
everything and not all that much it's
not going to tell us you may tell us
that we were going to have an expanding
its not going to tell us what that next
pandemic is going to be although it
might give us a range of possibilities
it's not going to tell us when that next
pandemic is going to arrive although it
might allow us to venture an educated
guess it's not really going to tell us
what we can do either to prevent the
next pandemic from coming or to control
it when it arrives although it may well
give us a range of possible options if
we can contemplate so how do we get how
do we navigate in between everything and
they're not all that much how do we use
history in a way that gets from history
what can be gotten but doesn't expect
history to give us what it can't give us
and that was I think it's an important
theme of our discussion earlier today
and one there are several points that
that were raised as important let me
just perhaps one
mentioned perhaps one or two one is that
when we try to use history to think
about the future or the present we
should be eclectic we shouldn't latch on
to one historical analogy or one
historical example of what historical
period and that's that so then you know
okay well influenza oh that's 1918 so we
know that that's not good if you if you
find yourself latching on to one
historical analogy and guiding your
actions then you probably on the wrong
track what you want to have is you want
to have a set of different possible
analogies and think through the
implications of each comparison what
does that mean that means that as
historians when we try to use a lot of
the stars saying earlier have various
kinds of palms about using history as a
guide to the present in the future we
even have a pejorative term without it's
called present ism which we hurl at each
other had moments of of dyspepsia but
nevertheless if we are inclined to this
exercise we need to think very carefully
about how we justify using a certain
historical analogy or a certain
historical experience to shed light on
present conditions or in future
possibilities and it when Howard was
giving his presentation today sorry hard
I'm stealing your anecdote shamelessly
but it's just too good to to not mention
he was talking about how he was invited
to to the White House to consult about
to lend his expertise on 1918 influenza
to the the recent pandemics care and and
then at some point a question arrived
from the President to the historian
asking him do you realize that 1918 was
a long time ago but that's pretty much
it right mmm and I actually think that's
not a bad question because it asks his
story to justify you know what about
1918 is sin
learn to our present condition that we
can legitimately use it as an analogy
and what about 1918 is different than
our present condition and which raises a
question of what type of history is more
useful are we making an argument that
the further we go into a less useful
history becomes so aged history nothing
at all medieval history not much you
know early modern maybe bit and modern
history yes that's most useful is that
the type of argument and willing to make
or are willing to make a different type
of argument that has a different kind of
taxonomy of usefulness and lack of
usefulness it's something we need to
think about as we try to use history as
a guide for the present and the future
finally I think that this question look
in history teach us about the next
pandemic also suggests another question
which is what can the next pandemic
teach us about history but no less
important in my view and there are all
sorts of answered possible answers to
this the most important one in my view
is that it teaches us in as much as we
know that the next pandemic is going to
be in one way or another of global
significance it may not be of global
scope but it will be of global
significance in fact the definition of
the word pandemic demands it what we
know is that history are thinking about
history needs to be global it needs to
be transnational and that might might
seem too many of you as a trivial
statement but those of us who are
historians here know that historians
have for a long time been trained to
work in national or regional boxes and I
think if there's anything that the next
pandemic teaches the features us about
history is that we need to escape those
confines and our thinking about the past
thank you very much eras and thank
please join me in thanking all the
panelists for those
fascinating opening remarks now the main
purpose of a panel discussion of course
is to have discussion so there's a
microphone there available for asking
questions and the panelists are also
free to ask each other thank you so much
very stimulating I want to draw from the
very rich literature of political
military strategy and how that applies
or doesn't apply to what you're talking
about in that field for the past 50
years when one looks at military
organizations one has been taught to
take a holistic view as to how they
perform in war that is we take into
consideration issues of class social
inequity the ability and effectiveness
of these kind of organizations to
actually fight now when you look at this
situation I'm curious what history can
teach us about the quality of the
national health systems of these
societies when they have to confront a
sudden crisis like this kavita was
talking about social inequity and class
problems in India I'm just wondering
what you you could and I think of the
Munich analogy which is applied to a
military strategy and political military
strategy in our thinking about how let's
say the vietnam war was waged does and
we know that the fallacies of it how
does a 1980 strat at 1918 model apply in
similar ways you know what is the
effectiveness of a national health
system when you compare it when you
think of it as a way to fight a disease
system and what we learn from history
about that well first let me complete
errors is a repeating of my anecdote the
answer to the president was yes mr.
president I know but it is a good
question there are similarities and of
course vast differences of how American
society lived and died and ate and did
all sorts of things in 1918 compared to
the present and of course we pointed
those issues out very carefully
in our studies and in our
recommendations travel was very
different there was railroad and there
were some cars but not a lot there were
daily shopping excursions for groceries
because you did not have refrigeration
in the same get ice boxes but not
refrigeration the same way it was a cash
economy so it was a day-to-day economy
there were stay-at-home mothers and
fathers who worked outside the home
primarily schools were very different
and in terms of the whole social fabric
of the country was quite a different
place and yet what was intriguing about
looking at 1918 and it was only as I was
saying earlier today one arrow and a
quiver of many arrows of trying to
understand what to do for a present a
pandemic by the way in terms of
prediction we're all predicting
something called h5n1 from Asia that was
what we were all worried about it was
h1n1 coming from North America so very
different planning that for one set of
circumstances in another but what was
similar in terms of looking at 1918 was
that our group was asked to look at what
are called non-pharmaceutical
interventions things like quarantine
isolation school closure gathering bands
public gathering means things that
became really extinct in the 50s and 60s
and 70s with very good vaccines and very
good antibiotics so to propose a
quarantine in the 1960s let's say you
would be laughed out of the room
literally by your colleagues it was just
an antiquated thing to do and yet it
became very important when we consider
things like bird flu in two thousand and
five and six and certainly in 2009 with
h1n1 because we know you cannot make a
hundred and fifty million dose
vaccine or 300 million doses of vaccine
if you need double shots that's just a
notice 350 Americans I'm not even
talking about other countries you can't
make that overnight the technology on
flu vaccines up until relatively
recently was very similar to the way it
was 50 years ago you need a lot a lot of
chicken eggs and your inject the virus
in and you're growing it and it takes
six or more months to get those doses
ready to be shot to be ready to be
tested and then injected into people's
arms there's certain technologies but
they wouldn't do all of it and maybe in
the next several years they will that
might take three months but that's still
quite a lag so if you wanted to look at
these non-pharmaceutical interventions
you really didn't have a database in the
modern post germ theory era that was
larger and had populations of a hundred
thousand or greater which is where most
of us live in the United States and this
was the United States study you don't
have much data other than 1918 so was it
a perfect data set far from it were
there problems with it in its
applicability to 2009 absolutely and the
President and others were very right to
ask that but was it absolutely not worth
a grain of salt as one very
distinguished virologist said and I
reply hope it's worth at least a shaker
assault far from that too and so there
were things that could be done and then
serve as a foundation for more modern
studies that's were set up and were
performed in 2009 but you're absolutely
right whoever asked i don't see you
standing anymore you know history can
serve as it can form the president you
have to be very careful about present
ism and i agree it's not only just Pepsi
it's generally disdain but it could in
front but if you're if you're suggesting
it's a guidepost for each milestone a
treasure map of where you need to go on
your scavenger hunt you're going to be
sorely disappointed and in this case
more than disappointed people are going
to die so I think you have to
use this data as carefully as you would
use any type of inquiry that it doesn't
give you the whole picture no one has a
lock on the truth as far as I know it
let me just add a little bit to that
because when I was doing it I wrote a
book of the co-author on are we ready
are we ready which was based on
interviews after September 11th and it
was an attempt to kind of capture
people's reactions before the historical
gloss kind of took over people in public
health and we were interviewing a lot of
people literally within months after the
attack on the world trade center one of
the people we interviewed was the head
of the CDC's environmental environmental
unit Center environmental health and he
was flown in literally the only plane in
the sky he said he was the only plane
the sky after September 11th when
everyone was grounded and he accompanied
by three jets flew into New York City
and saw the hole in the ground and
landed and he spent a lot of time in his
interview talking about the response and
his basic point as he said if it was
going to be if the attack on the United
States and if the attack of bio weapons
would be used in the United States I
mean this is how they were thinking he
was almost ecstatic that had happened in
New York okay and I said what do you
mean by that you know this is a bizarre
way of looking he said because you have
to understand every one of our public
health systems throughout the country
has different levels of capacity and the
thing that made New York really able to
respond was not the emergency plans it
had not the ways in which it responded
because it had spent a lot of time
although they had preparing for attacks
nobody forced saw an airplane going into
the into the building's they prepared
all sorts of plans but it was because in
New York there's an infrastructure that
existed there in which when the
buildings went down almost immediately
people who are interested in rat
in New York City's the Department of
Health went out made sure they busted
into restaurants to get the food out of
there so there was an infestation of
rats because the people in the
department of health that were concerned
about water pressure in the water system
made sure that all the leaks that were
created by the you know the destruction
of lower Manhattan suddenly didn't
reverse water pressure so that suddenly
you know waste water would end up in
people sinks that people who were
concerned about the records the vital
records of New York right would actually
rushed down to the 21 25 worth street to
go into the basement and load up trucks
to bring every record regarding birth
and death up to the Bronx he said
because the city has this extraordinary
tradition of an infrastructure built
around providing services for its people
it was almost as if they were they were
ready for this attack and he thanks God
it didn't happen Atlanta that it didn't
happen in Washington that it didn't
happen in a thousand other cities where
the infrastructure had been destroyed
the reason I bring this is one because
of your allusion to the you know the
military the military question but the
point he was making is that it was
almost because he was arguing about it
was because of this long history of
social democracy I mean I was a lot of
comment he literally used that word in
which city services were given in New
York that we were able to respond not
because of any special plan so I think
that history is really capable of
looking one of the things about the
pandemic in 1918 was that and the
studies that Howard did and all you know
some other people did of different
localities is how different the
responses were based upon both local
conditions local ideologies local
beliefs about who is responsible for
disease where it came from the local
prejudices of people all of which are
factors that are not planned out at in
any kind of central meeting it's based
upon a deep history historical knowledge
of culture of America you know what is
American values about who is
constable for disease what should be
people be doing these are all questions
that are rooted regionally nationally
and also internationally that really
historians can provide an extraordinary
you know panoply of you know insights
into if not answers for that question
about responsibility for disease it's
interesting that's come up several times
in tonight's discussion so just you
mentioned that Kavita also you know and
the contrast there nobody wants to own a
disease but you know a question someone
on that topic from a historical
perspective but also it may be most
applicable to professor Manila as the
author of the whistle wilsonian moment
in 1918 with Wilson doing a lot for
public health and trying to move the
ball forward in terms of public
responsibility over public health only a
few years later to suffer ostensibly
from the fluid the Paris conference and
have some of his goals at the parents
confluent conference rolled back because
of his inability to participate are
there other examples where the threshold
between administration and leadership of
global or public health issues where
that threshold is crossed and the
disease affects the ability to govern or
affects the ability to manage what
thinking is there about the ability for
these diseases to threaten the ability
to manage them itself that's a really
interesting question about which I think
more research could be done aims to
those of you who are thinking about your
summer research projects specifically
about about Wilson you know this is
general political stories don't usually
like to think about the impact of health
of individuals on political outcomes but
in fact oftentimes there is an impact
and in this case I it's not clear the
evidence is is I think in it is not
clear-cut in terms of whether Wilson had
the flu or not he had a history on the
other hand of
of hypertension and strokes minor
strokes and some people who's written
written about this think that he had
minor strokes in the course of the
spring of nineteen nineteen that
impaired his ability to negotiate the
Paris at the Paris Peace Conference de
versailles treaty what we do know for
sure is that he had a major stroke in
early October of 1919 that basically
destroyed any chance of getting Senate
ratification of getting successful
negotiations for Senate ratification of
the Versailles Treaty and in fact the
person whom I consider the most
knowledgeable Wilson biographer alive
John Milton Cooper wrote a book a few
years ago that basically says that had
Wilson not gotten that stroke not
suffered that stroke in the in October
of 1919 there's a very high likelihood
that the versailles treaty would have
been ratified that the united states
would have entered the league of nations
beyond their what how that would have
changed the future beyond that it's you
know and anybody's guess but i think
there is a pretty good case to make that
the the that the individual health of
that individual changed history at that
at that juncture in 1919 I've got I've
got another one that is sort of a
strange one and I'm not sure if the
analogy holds and I was thinking about
presidents and leaders and there's a
reverse one and correct me if I'm wrong
historians but but Adolf Hitler in world
war one was a direct participant of
chemical attack understood the humanity
if you will of using that form of
warfare um and although potentially
prepared to engage chose never to use it
now there are a couple of research and
gas chambers of course except except in
a very specific population but but but
interestingly in terms of in terms of
prosecution of the war effort itself um
you know there's an example where did it
make military sense to
possibly reuse these things well yes and
no I would he have achieved or would the
Nazis have achieved some sort of a
military advantage because none of the
none of the groups were prepared really
even by World War two to have effective
countermeasures against the against
chemical agents and and biological
agents in fact the the history of the US
is response to World War one and the bio
warfare capability was a direct result
of World War two and the belief that
possibly the Germans were using it and
it was all done under leadership George
Merck who is the principal architect of
the u.s. program of Merck
pharmaceuticals but but there's maybe
there's a context in a reverse sense to
the one that you're asking there's also
there's a huge amount of people who work
on presidential and leadership
disability most prominent is Larry
Altman former chief medical
correspondent for The Times who is
working now on a book at the Wilson
Center in Washington on not only
presidential disability but candidate
disability and he really pioneered the
notion of getting the health records of
both presidents and potential leaders
which i think is invasive but a very
good thing Franklin Roosevelt comes to
mind of course not only with his polio
and how that changed and altered his
leadership skills but he had terrible
malignant hypertension and the treatment
for that was phenobarbital which bar
bitch wit that really knocked you out
and so we have good not only
photographic evidence of how we looked
at Yalta and how he negotiated or failed
to negotiate Yalta and the result of the
Iron Curtain thereafter but also
wonderful medical records of how much he
was being dosed and the problems he was
having John F Kennedy comes to mind to
for his myriad of health problems Nixon
actually didn't get hauled into court
because the F libidus so his death
almost death-defying case of phlebitis
prolonged his agony with Watergate sup
Washington and smallpox so there's lots
of stuff a lot of that history by the
ways is bad retrospective diagnostic
history which is even worse than present
isn't but with with some of the more
modern cases we have good medical
records of that you know III wish
political historians would recovered
more because we are all humans what I
love about the history of Medicine in
history of disease is that it's really
the one thing that binds us all rich
poor black white African American
whatever we're all going to get sick and
die and so these these these
commonalities I find fascinating when
you're studying the human condition the
question was about the impact of
pandemics I thought and and and really
the place where this has been brought up
the most is in Africa where is argued
for four years that it was hot there's
this hollowing out effect because it's
bureaucrats educators business leaders
who were the ones who were most at risk
the interesting thing is that I don't I
haven't seen any study that's actually
sort of followed up on that and said did
it really happen um and it's maybe
someone else knows of studies that have
done that but it certainly was argued
and others have shown well you know that
that's making an argument that it wasn't
really hitting the poor and in fact we
know that it was much more hitting in
foreign was much more hitting at women
and so there was a question about where
that particular argument was coming from
and and why was being constructed and
how was being used but as I said I
haven't seen anything that's actually
going on and traced with of them had any
effect at all professor counter sorry
but it's just a couple of things quickly
I mean marching forward through time and
this is kind of you know bad you know it
would be considered bad research because
it's purely speculative but there are
many who speculate and trying to
understand why thabo mbeki denied the
link between hiv/aids it may be some
thought that he might have been eight it
might be HIV positive and that's purely
speculation I mean who knows but I mean
the perception in in some ways
politically I think was was important if
only in discrediting him perhaps but
another example is something that comes
out of Jane Mario spoke the dark side
where she relates an
not long after 911 when apparently one
of the biohazard detectors and the the
White House gave a false reading that
seemed to indicate that Cheney might
have gotten a fatal dose of anthrax and
she anyway argues that that was one of a
series of things that may have kind of
sent him off kilter and may explain some
of the poor decisions that came out of
the White House is it that those months
so this is you know these are just kind
of the kinds of things people speculate
about but obviously you know it's going
to take time for historians to do more
serious research but that question of
like how disease can kind of you know
destabilize or make us you know
understand differently how power is
exercised is something it's worth
pursuing I think I have a question about
the different levels of historical
analysis that might be useful in not
predicting but anticipating the course
of a pandemic and the example I'm
thinking of as cholera so you have an
evolutionary history of cholera in human
civilization some of the evidence is
spotty but it's there in archeology and
you can kind of see how cholera evolves
with urbanized human populations versus
rural populations in terms of water
supply and such and I'm wondering how
one might sort of compare or use that
sort of information with very recent
microbiological history of cholera and
the very rapid evolution of if any
bacterial infection how do you weigh the
anthropological and historical evidence
against more recent trends and against
the very rapid evolution of a bacteria
that's your favorite disease you said
that many times yes you did telling us
that was your fave
I knew I shouldn't have said that how
much has cholera really evolved since
we've become familiar with it well yeah
I mean you know it cholera is the great
19th century disease in terms of there
were six great pandemics we're still in
the midst of the seventh I believe now
but most of them are in the 19th century
and what they teach us best is an issue
that still concerns us but it's been
much sped up as the issue as humans
travel as transportation goes farther
and farther afield from origins parts of
origins to other places so do the germs
that reside within those people now in
the shipping industry particularly with
human migration from the early 1800s
well into the late 1800s you saw as
ships became faster going from 30 days
to about seven days to cross the
Atlantic and from about two months to
about 20 days to cross the Pacific
during that timeframe and a lot of
social disruption because of poverty and
social unrest and fleeing from one place
to another that was really a very early
taste of what happens when people move
and they move even faster now today it
also allowed Public Health people long
before that we knew that it was Vibrio
cholerae that cause cholera let alone
the evolution and issues that have
changed the Vibrio in recent years but
the idea that international strategy
strategies needed to be made so now we
talk about international health
regulations on a chart that are going on
at levels of wh 0 but also in national
health departments and ministries and so
on but from the 1830s well until 1938
obviously World War two stopped a lot of
things there were several international
sanitary conventions that were there to
discuss even though they often use
different disease ideologies miasma
other humoral theories and so on but
they're very fun to read through because
all the world's experts of the day are
there arguing about things but they are
at least thinking about germs of travel
and the notion that several people said
today that national boundaries alone
don't protect us there used to be a time
as a lot of the Atlantic is very wide
the Pacific is wider that's going to
protect the United States from things
but the notion that we are really a very
tiny planet really begins far earlier
than the late 20th century so that
that's one area in terms of evolutionary
biology I have a colleague at Michigan
who works a lot on Vibrio and various
evolutionary changes and also the better
tracking we have in identifying the
different forms of Vibrio which is also
similar to the different forms of e.coli
and the genetic uses of how we can make
those identifications has changed
markedly and so there I don't think
history is great use but it is
fascinating when you notice change over
time of morphology just looking through
a microscope and looking at anything
that looks like a comma bacillus that's
not necessarily all comma bacillus are
not the same so that's a real change
over time but I think we need to rely on
the new science for but now using
molecular methods also we're you know
trying in a sense to reconstruct the
evolutionary history of many of these
organisms and their their family trees
if you will there you know phylogenetic
relatedness you know which is a
different sort of history but you know I
think it's another use of history and we
do see the repetition of history with
many of these food and water borne
diseases so the e.coli o157 h7 which
caused hemolytic uremic syndrome
jack-in-the-box incident and all these
other foodborne infections in hamburgers
and then later once we learned to cook
hamburgers well in uncooked or unwashed
vegetables and so on now we see an
outbreak with a different but but very
similar kind of infection a different
e.coli in Germany which has caused a lot
of consternation there and those of you
who are here last week for dr. Hamburg
stockwell wreck
there's an awful lot of similarity in
this history in a sense repeating itself
even though the the organisms may have
evolved the pathogens may have evolved
in different ways we see great
similarities and it reminds us about the
globalization of the world the sort of
transnational world we live in today
socially by the way where collar is
really instructive is issues of
scapegoating and what we were talking
about earlier is concealment because it
is a traveling germ and really was
associated with port traffic many
countries during these 19th century
pandemics were very hesitant to admit
they had a problem and once the problem
was discovered it was already too late
and these are issues that plague us no
pun intended over and over and over
again the hesitancy to be transparent
and kept full disclosure and the irony
of all this I think is globalization may
actually save us because as the global
world includes all countries involved in
various businesses countries can't
afford to be excluded from the global
business community and what's ours
taught us and you know the business
commute in you to conceal things we
won't do business with you and so I find
that as you know fascinating and ironic
it that was very helpful in the flu both
were bird flu and subsequent issues
China has has acted in a much more
forthright manner so that's something we
can learn as well I think Howard well
have talked about the cost of Public
Health yeah we forget the history the
public health it's basically lost all
control over the cost of the
therapeutics need to treat any pandemic
occurs so I'd like to ask is to kind of
a two-part question one how has the loss
of other place in control of
therapeutics affected the ability of
public health to fight pandemics and
also are we getting to the point where
public health is being reduced to a mere
longest organization without any real
power to fight dynamics
well the first question is I think we
are a society that puts way too much
emphasis on magic bullets we're
fascinated particularly by one pill you
could take one time and cure all things
instantly with no side effects or
problems and it's our society has been
really socialized to believe that and
want that and seek that out and then
there's other economic and business
reasons why companies that produce these
magic bullets would want large purchases
of them and so if you look at the
expenditures for the last couple of flu
issues many many many many billions for
vaccines and tamiflu but much less money
for traditional public health mechanisms
surveillance mechanisms or even beefing
up local and state and federal agencies
where you have doctors and public health
experts pounding the pavement so to
speak I think that's a mistake I think
the approach to an epidemic and or a
pandemic is a multi-lane expressway and
you need all those lanes open and
running yeah so I I would prefer a more
equal distribution in those traffic
light box it responds to your second one
I'd like to hear some of the other
panelists as well as that I don't think
Public Health is an alarmist Chicken
Little kind of a thing I think the
people you know yeah I venmo that it was
like it would be the organization that
tells the role that there is a pandemic
we worry about you know panicking people
and how many times do we do that and I
think we need to be honest and
forthright we cannot predict the future
we are going to use various models and
it much advance information as we can
get but given all the things that
Professor Packard was saying is that we
still can't really predict things until
they they kind of have that we do much a
better job movie 100 years ago but you
know being informed concerned is very
different from informed panic and so we
have fire departments and ambulances and
police departments that are at the ready
all the time
in this neighborhood and we pay for that
and they sometimes go out on false
alarms but we never have that why do we
have a police force why do we have a
fire depart we want that because we know
that there's going to be some false
alarms for every real alarm and I think
we have to do a much better job of
explaining the public health departments
of the country from the local to the
national as well as the international
level have to be they're going to over
call and I think I think we'd prefer to
have them over call than under call and
that doesn't mean it's a failure that
means we're very vigilant anybody else
thank you let's take the next question
thank you hi thanks again for coming
everyone um my question is about sort of
the logistics of historical research I
suppose if scientists and historians are
to collaborate on the modern problems
public health it's going to be important
of course that they be able to talk to
each other and understand each other's
language within the scientific community
the gold standard for an experiment of
course is for it to be done several
times hundreds even thousands of times
and for the results always be the same
with in history of course we've
discussed the fact that it's not
circular you don't have numerous trials
for everything my particular interest is
in disease eradication which we've
managed once arguably twice with
smallpox and render pests and I'm
wondering what you think historians can
do to buck up the gravity of their
statements given what the scientific
community will expect in terms of a
robust argument you don't think we're
very robust
I would really wonder whether a lot of
public health science is really based on
such good you know 19th century concepts
of experiment and replication and kind
of called pop Aryan notions of
replicability I think that most public
health science is really very much as as
probably inexact and as tentative as
virtually any historical methodology in
fact probably more so i think when we
react when we think of epidemics as
constantly getting back to Rodians point
yet epidemics has constantly kind of
written as surprises and needing
emergency responses I think we find our
science and our history sometimes
getting distorted I think the point I
was trying to make before is that the
existence of an ongoing infrastructure
for dealing with the here and now in the
everyday both within the United States
and also for other societies it's
probably much more important in terms of
creating a responsible response to
epidemics and I think that there is kind
of a cultural prejudice against history
in the United States where we believe
that history does not does not have
scientific rigor if I think if you go to
Paris you'll find exactly the opposite
you know where everything is history and
no no you know contemporary evidence
really matters so it's a it's kind of
cultural issue about what is really good
evidence what is bad evidence and I
think it's some sense we've no we found
ourselves as a society believing in
numbers even if we don't understand them
and there's as much interpretation of
the numbers and as much interpretation
in the results of experiments as as
probably interpretations of history that
would be my modest modest statement
I'd also like to add that it depends
where the numbers are coming from so if
you look at the whole controversy about
you know the hiv/aids figures in South
Asia and the way in which the UN aids
responded to it so a lot of countries
contest where the data comes from so
public health data and science is also
about its space or location and a lot of
it is of course you know the collection
of the data in terms of where the wh 0
collects is you know there's there I
mean you see the politics of of data
collection and research as well and that
leads to also assumptions about what is
legitimate what do people accept and so
I mean I think when we talk about
science we also talked about you know
the demand and supply of science who
buys that evidence who accepts it and
you know which policymakers do or don't
and I think there's a certain amount of
of politics and looking at that science
as well so it's not only about the
method and the tools and the research
that you use but also eventually if you
are talking about how it will affect the
ways in which pandemics are administered
or what policy is coming to place we
have to look at the politics of where it
comes from and I just quickly wanted to
add to David's point about culture and I
think there's also you know there's a
whole sense of sage about pandemics
which is also related to where you are
located and the sense of why you you
know it has to do with I mean pandemics
all are also about you know the assume
that you have a certain cultural
imagination where you think you should
have disease free a completely
disease-free and a completely hygienic
environment so I'm not disputing the
fact that you do need you you know you
do need techniques to be able to you
know you you'll need you need public
health approaches but this this is this
business of thinking that you can
completely get rid of you know you can
have these zones where you can protect
yourself completely anticipate
everything it's also a certain kind of
assumption it's a kind of cultural
assumption which I think I don't really
agree with so I mean to just to this
question about science John Lewis gaddis
in the landscape of history which is a
book that those of you the program right
I think that as the first rating on the
list says that he after being asked
several times you know whether history
is scientific
he decided to invert the question and
ask you know what sizes are historical
and he arrived the conclusion the
numerous scientists numerous sciences
that we take for granted are in fact
ison such as evolutionary biology or
climate ology or paleontology our
historical they don't they're not based
on that I mean arguably no sciences in
fact based on this ideal type pop Aryan
model anymore not even in theory but but
there are recognized sciences that not
even that were never based on these
kinds of experimental techniques and and
I don't think any scientist in his right
mind in his or her right mind would
expect historians to come up with this
kind of replicable model they data
they'd understand my hopes that history
is what it is and you have to think
about in a way that is that allows for a
unique point in times but they also
wouldn't expect evolutionary theorists
to come up with that kind of
replicability exact thought out but I
would grant you that if you're looking
at research on the social determinants
of health if you read the wh 0
Commission report you do come away with
a sense of where's the beef that in fact
there has been a sort of understudying
of that have done in these kind of
rigorous fashion that connections
between various social factors and
disease outcomes and part of the problem
is it's really difficult to get those
funding that's not what the NIH likes to
fund right it's requesting it's
requiring people to think about things
in different kinds of ways than fit the
normal models of research and there was
a result of that we have really fairly
large gaps in our knowledge of these
things and so you're absolutely right we
need no more robust but it we also need
more funding to do them to get the
robust into the research might wanted to
thank you all again for being here today
it was an absolutely stimulating day for
those of us that were in the program so
thank you um my question I guess kind of
builds on the trend of globalization
that we were talking about um from a
historical perspective to what extent
does international cooperation and
coordination kind of filter into
pandemic or public health response
obviously in something like eradication
it's very
because you have to work across borders
and with other countries but in
something like the social determinants
of health which is an increasingly
important trend obviously in global
public health how does this idea of
cooperation with other nations sort of
come into play and I'm also thinking I
guess about quarantine in the way that
nations are willing to close down their
borders and to keep people there's a
transfer of information obviously but
people and goods are supposedly not
supposed to cross borders if you've got
infection acts in country why you don't
want it coming into countries edge so um
anything that you could shed light on in
that respect to be much appreciated so
in terms of international cooperation I
think even when we look at the
dissonance between international health
regulations and many of the epidemic
economic diseases acts that exist in
many countries is immediately a
disconnect because in South Asia for
instance you have countries that have a
colonial epidemic diseases Act which
names certain kinds of diseases as a
priority you don't for instance name
SARS and other things which are you know
symptomatic rather than you know named
is epidemic diseases they aren't even
highlighted as being sort of the sorts
of diseases that need to be reported and
the international health regulations of
course have been reformed recently so
you do have issues you know you have
conditions or symptomatic conditions
like SARS that can be reported but
there's a discount in terms of the
international health regulations
national level laws that comes up to
mind immediately and I'm not really sure
how you can how you can have the wh 0
enforce these changes within the member
states themselves and as far as the
social determinants of health is
concerned I think there was a recent
article by an academic at York who
actually she looked at the definitions
of social determinants of health the way
they've been defined within countries
and across countries no no no belt burns
yeah and there's known there's almost no
consensus on that and you know you have
a chronic disease conference coming up
in September in 2011 in New York in fact
and everyone all the free conference
meetings are suggesting a social
determinants of health approach there's
a Jakarta call for action which
social determinants of health no one
really knows what the other person means
so it's a whole lot of blind men an
elephant is no way but the talking about
the same but you know international
quarantine policy over the last several
hundred years is sillier than a Marx
Brotherhood I mean it really is and it's
filled with in consistencies and
contradictions and it becomes a real
political hot potato in our modern era
just because there's a long history of
this marks brother behavior doesn't make
it any less Mark's brother like today
and so when you for example during SARS
when wh 0 did order a travel advisory
was the quarantine it is advising people
that cost the city of toronto millions
and millions of dollars in travel
conventions etc etc when they threatened
to do that more recently the State
Department volved in a V and flu was
rage in a raging they were concerned
indonesia threatened you know we're
likely to be the first place where avian
flu breaks out in humans human human
subjects and you're going to need us to
give you viral samples so that you can
develop vaccine so if you quarantine or
prevent us from traveling back and forth
we're going to do that to you there was
arguments between france and the united
states over such travel advisory issues
and so on so when I upset in dialogues
of this we've all just you know raised
our hands the year that could you really
do anything and it also brings up
another issue that may not it's known to
everybody at this table and I'm sure
many people in the room but let's just
reiterate wh 0 World Health Organization
sounds very powerful and very large and
it's quite the opposite and it does not
have the resources the power or the
legal mandate to shut down countries or
you know they can advise you and that
has a big impact but it's not the same
as what we could do in New York City
today if something broke out so that
needs to be articulated to it I think if
the history teaches us anything in a
canoe
t Chisholm is that there is a lot of
contradiction and a lot of fear of
retaliation and that has been going on
since time immemorial since Emperor
Justinian ordered some of the first
quarantine orders seventh century AD the
constancy of human nature it will be
interesting to see how the international
the revised international health
regulations play out a one last question
thank you everyone and I really
appreciate how you all spoke by the
social determinants of health and as a
medical historian I'm thinking about
what is missing in our field in terms of
politicizing all of the economic issues
that have impacted sort of all the
variety of diseases that we're dealing
with now how can the field of medical
history sort of improve the way that
we're looking at the history of disease
and health so as to account for the
social history of of health outside of
you know a lot of topics that were seen
which are kind of micro histories of
diseases or technologies that emerged
the first thing is that the really the
the history of disease in a kind of
epidemiological sense you know tracing
diseases linking him up to social
conditions and so forth has not been a
major center of the history of Medicine
I would argue um history of Medicine has
looked at history of concepts of disease
much more friendly and much more readily
on how diseases are understood and dealt
with entreated but the whole notion of
sort of looking historically at diseases
as if they are actually real entities as
well as opposed to sort of conceptions
is a controversial one and there are
historians that are very resistant to
that even notion so so it's actually a
harder battle than then suggested but I
think that those of us who take this
seriously are trying very hard to bring
in larger context in which we understand
the history of disease and it's it's
it's important you know I think there's
a lot more to be done in this field but
it's not without content
yeah i think that the history of
medicine is you know kind of a
problematic conception outside of the
world of history just because it
identifies medicine is some kind of
unique entity that is different from
other social processes and that leads us
you know into a bind in the course I I
teacher at Columbia I start out with
something that probably escapes
everybody and by the end of the semester
people are chanting it which is now that
we build the world to kill us that the
worlds of disease are emblematic of the
cultures and the societies in which we
in which we develop them whether it be
epidemic diseases in the 19th century as
a symbol of the crowding of cities and
urban organization and/or ultimately
chronic and infant in industrial
diseases of the 19th 20th and you know
21st century's as being in some sense
representative of the new industrial
state and relations we've created it's
an American course so it's not a world
history course but the point you know I
think what escaped students at the
beginning suddenly becomes a real
organizing principle by the end and by
the end they understand you know and
walk into the prep for the final and
kids are you know chanting in unison we
build the world's that kill us and then
I think they've got the point of but but
the point is that in the history of
Medicine has to think of what that
history is differently they have to
think of medicine is a kind of a
byproduct of the social of a sub social
relationships and at that point then it
becomes clear how to organize the myriad
of problems from from infectious disease
through epidemic and pandemic through
chronic and all the other conditions
that we decide our diseases at different
moments they're kind of the you know the
the angst of of human living of the
existential meaning of life and that you
know that's you know our responsibility
I think of educators when we think of
the future of the history of medicine
isn't filled in some sense break down
that boundary between it and and the
other forms of history that are kind of
now dominant in
perhaps history departments but not in
the worlds of history of Medicine
Department okay reason maybe for this
medical exceptionalism if you will is
that the roots of the field of history
of medicine was often medical doctors
who are writing their own professional
history internal its history and so was
often a history of great generally men
goes back there was more male dominated
and and great cures or great triumphs
and great diseases and I think I would
say I agree entirely with what David was
saying and I think it goes to what I was
saying earlier that if you are studying
the history of disease and I would kind
of it a lot of historians or work
studying history of disease and thinking
about it as entities not just as social
constructs in fact if you think disease
is only socially constructed I suggest
you think about that the next time
you're in bed with one you'll find it
there quite real but the reality that we
all as humans are going to get sick we
are all with the common bind of us is it
we're all going to share certain
diseases certain number of people here
are going to get cancer let's certain
another number of people are going to
get heart disease we know this and
others are going to get infectious
diseases and so i use it really is a
prism to study humanity history of
disease in medicine and health and cures
and disease entities is really just one
other way of looking at the human
condition if you look at a more narrow
way that I think that prism starts to
distort rather than clarifying so we
have to take care of that but in terms
of the question that somebody has how
can met you young medical stories to it
keep reading keep writing keep exploring
and keep explaining all of the things
that you're going to be finding out and
eventually somebody's going to listen
hopefully so last question thank you
thank you professor Morris and I'm sorry
I probably am asking questions that were
dealt with all day today but it occurs
to me that were not in this country a
society without crisis planning or
contingency planning my question
ultimately is
to go to is it doctor court yes my good
and the CDC has endless pronounced
occasions I've heard about ring
vaccination with elaborate charts there
are as Professor Packard pointed out the
orthogonal orthogonal prognostications
in the late 80s about the African
Leadership and and how they were not
only spreading aids because they married
late but also they were indeed perhaps
going to leave certain countries without
leadership I mean it goes on and on and
on now obviously contingency planning is
a military matter and always has been
and I'm wondering if you could talk a
little bit about lucema read because I
know that the military was investigated
for instance the clades the various
clades of AIDS were done by the military
I wondered if you could discuss some of
that and how it would affect not only
the government but also some aspects of
public health planning well first of all
I have to dissuade you of your notion
that at the CDC there's a rich
repertoire of contingency plans and
concepts of operations that they can
instantly reach and pull off the shelf
and and flip through in a protocol
fashion and as a matter of fact one of
the very interesting lessons that we're
experiencing as we take and i'll use the
the bio defense pathogens right now and
look at them agent by agent by agent and
ask how prepared are we really what are
the measures that you use what metrics
convince you that in fact were prepared
knowing that we never truly will ever be
prepared and and from my 22 years of
military history or military experience
there's a famous adage that says no we
designed all these operational plans and
war plans and the adages no plan
survives first contact with the enemy so
you know
we love to think that we're that we're
planning that we that we looked ahead
now to that extent as as we looked at
and as the White House an earlier today
we talked about h5n1 and the exuberance
with which the the former administration
looked at investment for protection
against a theoretical semi theoretical
threat with h5n1 yes there were human
cases yes they were always associated
with some direct involvement with with
an environmental orzo anodic contact but
the the fear factor of should it come to
our shores we certainly need to be
prepared so historically at this point
you see the development of a national
strategy or pandemic flu you see a
national implementation plan there are
hundreds of pages of who does what to
whom at what point in know very well
scripted a dialogue of where we will
stand Howard mentioned earlier today
that a demonstration of a chart you know
we had these things called pandemic
severity indices if you're one admit the
following you at five admit the
following and I came into the game it
during the h1n1 at a period of time
where I had not had any investment in
the development of those plans so I it
was kind of fortuitous and I looked at
the plans and and I challenge anybody to
when you go back and look at these so
you'll see this that these columns of
events that you follow according to this
and the way he interpreted was column
one which is which is the least
concerning was do almost nothing though
the furthest column which was pandemic
severity five you know you it was do
everything and the column in the middle
was you decide
um and and so you know it was a way of
trying to grapple with when we see a
truly life-altering fifty percent
mortality event which was the prediction
based on the human cases that we saw how
are we going to deal that we've never
had we've never had a disease in this
country where there's fifty percent
mortality so you know right off the bat
this would truly be in calamitous and
and we would all responded in ways that
are tremendously unpredictable I think
you know to to do it in a theoretical
model as the way they did it you know
they tried their best now why was it
important well what was important was it
prepared us for h1n1 so the presumptions
that would happen over in South
southeastern Asia that we would have
weeks months to prepare for it that over
the course of time we would be able to
ramp up our infrastructure with suddenly
challenge to win you know it happened
700 miles from our southern border and
is and that's nothing that's that's next
door but all the all the levers that
were in play with a pharmaceutical
companies with the CDC with access to
experts uh with thinking about how do we
shift rapidly yeah we'll throw away for
the time being we played a little bit
with the community mitigation techniques
saw that in this particular case it
didn't work spent a lot of time early on
scratching our heads about what the are
not values were and you know what was
the transmissibility of this wondered
why when why we hadn't spent the years
that we had at our disposal to really
develop a robust surveillance system to
ask what are the denominators when I
asked well how many people in New York
City have been infected not how many
have been sick how many been infected
there is no way of doing that so all of
these lessons learned I think we were
slightly better prepared because of a
notional preparation for something which
would have been truly monumental
didn't fit the bill necessarily but at
work now I wish I could say that that's
the case for every one of the other
problems that we see we're working along
those lines but you know I really am a
strong believer in it's not necessarily
the plan but it's the planning it's the
people that the context that you make
and the ability then to reach out
because you've got a network of system
of people that have thought through and
and therefore are better prepared to
respond more flexibly when the event
actually happens so ultimately to people
is you history is largely about people
in context and that maybe you know
highly highly relevant to these
questions I think the bottom line is is
that pandemics are by definition rare
events and that history is one of the
few tools we have available to try to
extrapolate from these rare events what
might happen in the future I think as
our panelists have pointed out it can be
a very useful tool but obviously has to
be used wisely and well and and
critically next week in this very same
place at six o'clock dr. Robert Webster
one of the world's authorities on the
ecology of influenza will be giving the
lecture on Thursday nights and I hope
that you'll all be able to attend and
enjoy that I want to thank all of you
and we'd like to thank all of you for
for coming and for your interest and
please join me in thanking our
distinguished panelists for
you